so how do you structure your go ups who
here has had this question at least once
in their life not surprised right
not surprised I think everybody who
starts out with go and even after you've
been going doing go for a while it's a
very common question it's probably one
of the first questions that you ask
probably some of these questions popped
to your mind so when I started out I was
like okay do I put everything just in
the main package do I start out with one
package and then break out in two
packages over time and just kind of
trust the organic growth of my app how
do you decide when something should be
in its own package should you just use a
framework and let that take care of that
what's the actual sort of idiomatic go
recommendation for structure is there
such a thing should you go towards micro
services should you start with the
monolith when you know how do you decide
how much do you share between packages
should your packages be completely
independent even if it means some copy
and paste or is you know is there a
sensible way of sharing some things and
splitting them up and I think that's
that's those are some very common
questions for you and experienced
developers alike application structure
is not mentioned or discussed that often
there are some resources online but it's
not really something that you can find a
lot on online um everyone seems to have
a slightly different answer to this
everyone seems to have their own
preferences which is completely fine but
there doesn't seem to be like a
unanimous this is how you do go and this
is how you structure of things and go
and go as a language there's already
give you many hints I mean it doesn't
really steer you in any particular way
which is great because you can just
experiment and do whatever you want but
at the same time it's not very intuitive
it might be hard for beginner
programmers especially it might be a
slightly higher level of a sort of
barrier to enter entry
so like I said these are all the
questions that I had myself as well this
is me in Iceland a month ago that like
mark mentioned I've been a software
developer for about seven years now so
not a huge amount of experience and I've
been doing go for about two years full
time so I wouldn't say I'm an expert I
don't consider myself an expert yet but
I've written some production apps
already and so I started out with PHP
and then Java and then I moved to go and
I'm still fairly unsure about some
things and go but I think over time I've
kind of worked out some ideas for how
you could structure your app or what are
what are the best practices that seem to
be out there in the industry so this is
where the idea from before this talk
came came about it was like a very
personal struggle that I had why should
we care about structure you might be
thinking like yeah sure but like stress
is this really important like end of the
day if it works it works right well Dave
Chinese say it said probably on this
stage because it was a keynote back in
2016 and at Galang UK if go is going to
be a language that companies invest in
for the long term the maintenance of go
programs the ease of which with which
they can change will be a key factor in
their decision to go with go unavoidable
pun so I was like yeah totally like that
makes sense like maintainability of your
project is a very big factor when you're
deciding about a language and if you
don't have a good structure for your
projects then you just find yourself
with inevitably with mess over time and
it'll be very frustrating and I think
we've all been there regardless of which
programming languages I think we've all
had come across projects which just
didn't really have a structure and they
just felt very messy and you didn't even
know how to go about fixing it so let's
define what a good structure actually is
I think it should first and foremost be
consistent across the entire project I
think and it really frustrates me when
there are several different styles in
the same app and as a newcomer to the
application not necessarily a newbie
programmer but just
and after you've never seen before and
you're not sure which ones which style
you should follow because you see like
oh this part is done this way and this
part is done this way so like which
which style should you stick to I think
your structure should be easy to
navigate easy to understand and easy to
reason about so it basically should just
make sense by looking at the code it
should make sense to you I think it
should be easy to change fairly loosely
coupled I think if you just wanted to
make a small addition here a small tweak
here you shouldn't really need to change
the entire up suddenly it should be as
simple as possible but no simpler and I
really like this quote I think so this
is attributed to Einstein there's some
debate around it I think this reflects
the go way of doing things that you
might to go perfectly so keep it sort of
as simple as you can but not simplistic
the design of your app should reflect
exactly how the app works because
ultimately your code is the most
up-to-date documentation of your
software you'll ever have so if the
design reflects exactly how the software
works there is no wandering about oh but
like the docs say that it does this but
it doesn't seem to be doing this so I
think a good structure basically is the
best version of the documentation for
yourself toward that you can have and
then conversely the structure of your
code should be what you set out to do in
the first place so like if you start out
with a certain design that structure
should ideally achieve what you set out
to do so I said there will be some beer
in this there might not be actual beer
but it will be some beer in this talk I
like doing talks where I sort of talk
about some real-life examples or fairly
realistic examples I don't like doing
talks where I just talk about foods and
bars because that's not what real life
is and we all know how to structure is
simple here is a food class here is a
bar class here is that how they can make
how they made ins right but how do you
go about reasoning about slightly bigger
projects so imagine I gave you this spec
to implement so let's say we want to
implement a be reviewing service service
so I
the user to be able to add a beer add a
review for a beer I would like the users
to be able to list all the beers I'd
like them to be able to list every all
reviews for a given beer and just for
the funsies let's say we want to have
two options for storage Jason files or
in memory and obviously you could add as
many as you want and I also want the
ability to add some sample data so just
to populate the whichever storage I pick
with some sample beers and some sample
reviews so for somebody simplicity like
I said we'll skip deletes updates skip
some tests and skip some error handling
so obviously this is just a demo up so
let's have a look at a few different
ways in which we could go about
implementing this and this is where my
magical switching hopefully will happen
whoops
I've gone the wrong way with the mouse I
think there we go so it's a slightly
blurry but I will open these and then
zoom in can you guys all see this or
should I work on zooming this in anyway
it doesn't really matter what's on this
screen that much I will zoom in for the
important bits so I have my main
function which basically does is calls
populate beers and populate reviews so
populate the sample data and I just
creates the Rueter defines the roots and
the files that we have here is data go
for the sample data and we've got a
model go which defines the review struct
and the beer struct fairly intuitive and
we've got a storage go which defines the
storage interface because we you know
probably some of you already jumped to
the conclusion that because we have
different types of storage we should
probably abstract that and have an
interface for it and then the the actual
implementation so we've got a storage
Jason and storage memory for the to
implementation that is all sitting under
one root directory flat it's all in the
main package so that's the most obvious
way to start with something like this
and the August Pro is that it's easy to
navigate for a small app like this I see
no problem with just doing it in flat
files it's the best way to avoid the
risk of running in circular circular
dependencies because it's all in the
main package so you'll never run into
that problem which is good I think it's
a good starting point when you're not
sure what structure you should not adopt
maybe starting with flat files is just
the simplest way to start and it's
fairly easy to then go and like start
extracting packages over time and so I
think there was nothing wrong with this
there's nothing wrong with Doug that
keep it sweet and simple approach at
least for I think it works pretty well
maybe for up to like 1020 business up
operations in your app I think you can
still achieve it pretty nicely with flat
files whoops wrong way around so this is
just a summary of what was in the editor
I've taken out the dependency files and
all the nonsense but essentially this is
this is sort of the gist of it looking
at those files can you tell just by
looking at the names what this app does
I mean you can probably guess it maybe
as a server because as it handlers ago
storage Jason storage mam you can
probably guess that it you know has
those two but it doesn't actually tell
you what this app does it doesn't
mention beers doesn't mention reviews so
you actually have to go into the code
and open the files and look through the
code to find out what this app actually
is about I think that flat files are
great for smaller apps for bigger apps
they can be hard to navigate over time
especially once those files start to
grow large or if you just suddenly have
to start having 20 30 40 files that's
the downside you also kind of it's easy
to use global State in this structure
and that might be slightly risky because
global State is generally discouraged
and that structure doesn't really
prevent you or discourage you if you
from using it so let's see if we can
maybe break this up or like somehow
group those those things together
grouping by function what do I mean by
that this is something called the
layered architecture and you essentially
divide your code into three or however
many layers you start with the sort of
somewhat some of the things have to do
with presentation in the user interface
layer some of the things have to do with
business logic like the core logic of
your app some of the files are for
external dependencies like databases or
whatever third party things you might be
talking to so if I know maybe jump to
the editor just close all these things
there we go so I've got essentially
three directories handlers models and
storage because you know some of these
things are to do with the server and the
endpoints and the handlers the models
which is the essential sort of struts
the beers and the reviews and then the
storage so inside of inside each it's
just few files so storage has Jason and
memory models have beer review and
storage so these just define the structs
it's just that they're now in their own
files and then the handlers just have
the actual HTTP handler so get beers at
beer and so on and so forth there's this
film thing still I still have a file
called data code that is kind of really
hard to put somewhere because like where
does the sample data go doesn't it's
kind of like just outside of everything
I mean could maybe go with the models
but not quite not quite with the
handlers so I've just left it in the
main in the root directory and then the
main just kind of ties it together so
main dreamers does the same thing so
calls are populating and then just
creates the HTTP router so all of this
might look familiar to you because all
this stuff like controllers models views
daos
that's a classic MVC so we probably all
know this from other languages or other
frameworks the pros of that approach is
that it's easy to decide where what goes
where I mean unless you've got something
like the data which is a bit ambiguous
but generally if you've got a handler
put it in handlers if you've got a model
put it in models so it's really easy to
decide especially if you're just coming
into the app what should go where the
Global's might start to be a bit
problematic because you might now have
to share some things between different
packages and so you might have to start
passing things in to your stripes so for
example if you create like a database
like instance of a structs or something
and then that needs to be used by the
beers and the reviews you can have to
start passing that in so the global
state is kind of slightly from you sir
you have to start passing things more
still looking at this
even though you've got the it kind of
gives you a slightly better idea of what
the app does because even though the
package names don't really tell you what
the app does once you look into the the
packages to see the names of the files
you can kind of see be a review storage
it still doesn't tell you what you can
do with this app but it kind of tells
you a little bit more about what what
it's about there are some other things
like naming talent dilemmas that start
creeping in here so if you've got your
models let's say you had like a user
model do you call it users or user so
it's the whole singular plural and do
they all go in one file do you have
separate ones for users and for user or
like separate one for beers and a
separate one for beers so you might have
some start having dilemmas like this and
this kind of is also hard to extend over
time because once you have 10 or 20
different handlers and 20 50 however
many models like those directories those
layers those packages just start growing
uncontrollably and you kind of get to
the point where they all group
completely different things together so
that's a slight downside the biggest
problem about this particular app though
and probably quite a few of apps like
this is that this won't actually compile
because you've got circular dependencies
in this case our beer model sorry our
handlers they depend on the storage to
add beers so they depend on the storage
package to save the beers but then the
storage package depends on the models
because they saved the beers and they
use the beer struct from the models the
package so they use this strap here and
so you've got a circular dependency
between those three that storage depends
on models that depends on storage
because you have a storage interface
which is in the models because it just
defines an interface that calls some
storage package memory things and then
that calls the models so the beer models
so you've got a dependency between the
storage package and
and the models package not circular
dependency and if you try to compile it
it would just say I can't so that's the
biggest downside
[Music]
sorry I've gone the wrong way again oh
there we go - that's one go so how about
we try grouping by module so for example
beers reviews and storage but like in a
slightly different so take the the
modules and actually name the packages
after that so rather than the function
it's more about like the module the
group of it so I've got that in here
oops
so the packages are now beers database
or storage forgotten every name it and
reviews let's close these ones how does
that look inside so we've kind of
grouped the handlers and the models
together because there so now everything
that is about beers goes into that
package and everything that is about
reviews goes into that package
everything is about the storage goes in
here so you've got the genuine Erik
struct definition as well as the
implementations and then main again ties
it all together pretty much doesn't
really change so same thing populating
and then just creating the rotors so the
naming is kind of worse in this case
because you've got a beer stop beer and
that's the stutter that you Jen you
should try and avoid and go so in this
in this particular example like it's
just get gets harder with the naming
because now we've got reviews review and
you've got storage storage or database
storage so the naming isn't particularly
pretty in this case and it's hard to
decide as well whether it reviews really
belong in their own package or do they
belong in beers because it's technically
reviews of the beers so you can argue
both ways you could argue that it's it's
its own thing or it's actually like a
sub module of beers and then that is
slightly it might be slightly hard to
decide then like what are you you know
what's a top-level package and what's
like a sub package of another package
you also have circular dependencies in
here and I think it's the exact same on
so I think database depends on the beers
I think yeah so you've got the beers and
reviews here and then the beer and the
handler actually depends on the storage
here so you've also got circular
dependencies between those packages
because they're all just treated equal
and that has the same at the same level
so this also won't compile and then you
also have like some weird outer naming
clashes like if you've got you've got
adjacent as the storage type and then in
our Jason in the actual Jason
implementation I had to name adjacent
storage because I couldn't name the
struct and the constant for the types
Jason because that would be a name clash
so you get some kind of if you basically
throw different things under the same
module and those things might need the
same name that might lead to some
problems and it's still hard to know
what this app does or where I should use
what like if I open up the handler
function and start looking at the
functions I still don't quite know like
if I if I just wanted to add a review I
would have to look at the code to figure
out you know is my add review function
going to be in this package or in this
package so it's not very intuitive to
know like how should I use this code if
I just wanted to call a function so it
kind of does get rid of some problems
but replaces them with RS compare to the
function like functional split
how about we try and group it by context
so go one step further again what do I
mean by context if we come back to the
spec let's think about what are we
dealing with here actually well we're
dealing with beers we're dealing with
reviews we're dealing with some storage
it's probably an API because it sounds
like an API and we also have this sample
data to to figure out so these are the
elements like our context that we're
dealing with in this problem in this app
it so it kind of this defines the world
of this app so if you were to formalize
it a little bit more you can start
thinking about what everything is in
this big world so as a context well we
know it's an HTTP API for adding beers
in terms of the language that we use to
describe this app or like our
terminology we can settle on beer review
let's call it repository or storage or
database very often you'll you'll find
three or five different words used to
describe the same thing in the project
and then when you want to implement
something new you're then wondering
which one of the three or five words
should I use like which which one did we
settle on the entities here is the HTTP
server the services that this app
provides is adding a beer adding a
review listing either of those things
our value object so the the sort of
objects that we're dealing here is beers
and reviews what are the possible events
that we might have happening in this app
well we might get like a beer added
successfully or review at it
successfully we can have a beer already
exist if we're trying to add a duplicate
beer not found if we're trying to list
something that isn't there in terms of
storage or repositories well we know we
need to store the beers somewhere in the
reviews somewhere and then in terms of
sort of things that will let us
manipulate this data those value objects
we need something to handle the beer
aspect of things so like a beer ad er a
beer list ER review either a review
Lister so we kind of need those those
entities as well so
for those of you who already are
familiar with it might have been getting
some hints and also I thought that for
it's very nice that you came here
instead of Sean stalk but for those of
you who are feel like you're missing out
on the Corgi gifts I found this one last
night so I figured I'll stick it in here
as the drum roll because what I just
what I just spoke about is something
called dee dee dee what is dee dee dee
domain driven development somebody told
me about it randomly about a year ago
and then they told me about this book
this book is a brick like this fake and
it's very academic and it's very very
formal but it's actually a pretty like I
I thought it was a very intriguing idea
for how you might start thinking about
your apps so this is a classic book by
Vaughn Vernon I encourage you to read it
to kind of get a full understanding but
I'll try and I'll try and explain it in
a slightly shorter and less academic
academic way so what is it about it's
about establishing your domain and the
logic first so before you write a single
single line of code you just think about
what are you dealing with
so what DDD is about is about defining
what they call a bounded context and
establishing the building blocks of your
system so it's something a value object
is something a repository what are what
are the things that we're dealing with
and you define a bounded bounded bounded
context which is basically a limit of a
particular model so like if like your
beers might be one context and then the
review might be another context and that
kind of defines what has to be
consistent within one context and what
can just work independently and then you
also define this thing called ubiquitous
language which is essentially your
terminology that you so you use set out
and you set on the particular
terminology to use across your project
and then ddd kind of distinguishes
between the entities the value objects
the main events aggregates all those
things that I just mentioned
that's like formalized in the DDD model
so actually Before we jump into this let
me just quickly show you an example way
that you could go about implementing
that this is obviously just my take on
this and the fun thing about DDD is that
every one of us might have a slightly
different idea for how to go about
implementing this so this is just what I
wore what makes sense to me and how I
would do it but this is by no means just
one way
so I've I thought about this app this
way well we're gonna have an adding
package and then the review of reviewing
package and it's essentially so DDD
promotes this this idea that you named
your packages after the functionality
that they provide and not after what
they contain so the functionality
provided here is adding listing
reviewing but it doesn't so the names
aren't after what that package contains
and I do have a package called beers and
reviews just to define the structs and
then the main again ties everything
together it looks pretty much the same
it's just like a slightly different way
of initializing things but you still add
the sample data still the finer HTTP
roots
it's just that in your packages for
example in the adding package I have the
endpoints and now this is like separated
so this is just the HTTP layer and then
they also have the service the actual
business logic so the add beer and add
sample beers function so it's kind of
slightly more grouped so this will be
just the HTTP layer this is the actual
logic and then storage is the actual
implementation so I just have the type
for defining the type but then this is
the actual bit to deal with actual
saving of things so this is kind of if
you do your code in this way it's like
easier to avoid circular dependencies
because then you the flow is slightly
more clear it's it's slightly clearer
because it starts at the main and then
you kind of the adding the reviewing the
listing will depend on the storage but
then the storage won't want so much
depend on this so it's slightly easier
to avoid circular dependencies when you
start thinking about your apps this way
because you didn't start to think about
the flow of control and information and
I'll come back to that in a minute so
like I said this is just my take on it
a few slight problems with it if I
wanted to suddenly add a different way
of interacting with this app so rather
than an HTTP API I would like to be like
I'd like to for this to be a command
line up that will just prompt me for
beers where do I then put that new
client or maybe it's just like a
completely new completely separate
clients that interacts with my
application so where where would I put
that in this project and then the
sampling sample data is still fairly
ambiguous it's now thrown into so like
the sample beers are the final defined
here and then in the actuals adding
service you can adds beer or add a
sample beer but it kind of doesn't feel
quite right because then you're just
mixing the sample beers with the actual
business logic so
there is something that can take us one
step further from here and help us a
little bit with that with that dilemma
particularly about how you interact with
your app and this is something called
the hexagonal architecture model this is
this was invented like invented
popularized by alistair cockburn and
it's pretty popular these days so what
is this hexagon all about it has the
core domain in the center so the core
domain is in here and then it kind of
starts to have layers that go outside so
you've got your application layer of
framework layers and then at the very
edges it's all the third parties that
you might be dealing with the input
inputs and the outputs so you're gonna
have your databases maybe some third
party services for it party parties API
all of they all of the outside world
then so the main application logic is
here in the center and like the goal of
this model is basically the goal of
approaching in the design this way is so
that changes in one area of the app
effect as little of the rest of the app
as possible so changes to your ideally
changes to the core domain should only
affect the core domain they shouldn't
change how you your storage works and
equally if you just want to swap out the
storage like if you want to swap out a
my sequel database for a new sequel
database or something like that you
shouldn't necessarily touch your domain
logic your domain logic shouldn't really
care how and where you save your data
like it should have that abstracted so
the hexer architecture is all like I
said before like it treats the inputs
and outputs as the external dependencies
it doesn't have like this this sort of
cement it's basically completely a
symmetric as opposed to the layered
model which kind of very clearly defines
like the inputs and then the the
business logic and any outputs like view
so this one just treats it all as kind
of the same thing and then the key thing
about the hexagonal motor is that
dependencies are only allowed to point
inwards and that is a very key thing
about this so the idea is that nothing
from the core domain should depend on
anything outside of it
but the things outside of it can by all
means use the things defined in the core
domain and that going to make sense from
a lot from like the way you would think
about your apps so it kind of makes
sense to group the the actual called
CoreLogic together and then just leave
all the everything else that can be
swapped in and out all the adapters all
the parts that's why it's kind of called
the ports and adapters sometimes it
makes sense to just leave it outside and
so the hex model achieves this by making
a very heavy use of interfaces so you
pretty much define define interfaces at
every single boundary between the layers
so the core domain is going to abstract
everything it doesn't need to know about
as interface and it will kind of just go
outwards so interfaces are very heavily
used in this model and if I there we go
so to give you an example of how you
might go about implementing that it's
actually very similar to the domain
driven model except for I now put two
top-level packages so there is a package
called command and a package called
package PKG and that's something that
you might have noticed in some of the
projects are out there online so the
command package kind of defines the
entry level into your app so you've got
so i've got my data sub package and my
server sub package now i have two main
functions and one of them is for the
actual server so it just defines the
endpoints as it did before but now the
adding of sample data is a completely
separate command so it's completely
independent from the server which kind
of makes sense because that's how you
would think about this up to start with
so now my mind doesn't always add sample
data when i run it i only add sample
data when i decide to run this main file
and if i wanted to add a third party
client to call my app or a command line
interface like entry into my app I can
just add another sub package under my
command package that just starts that or
like lets me interact with my
application in a different way so it's
very easy to add new inputs to this and
then the package package contains the
actual core logic which doesn't
isn't concerned with how this app is
accessed or anything it's just it has
the same functionality so adding listing
reviewing none of that changed the
storage package is outside of the
package of the pkg package because it
isn't strictly sort of business domain
it's probably debatable whether you'd
put it all under the package which is
sort of supposed to be your actual
source code for the application or if
you leave it outside I don't have a
strong opinion on that I think you could
argue both ways and on any out of file
so like I've got a godet file in here
all of that is under the routes
directory so that's kind of how you
could group this in a hex model looking
at the package names again it tells you
a little bit more about what this app
does so you look at just the by looking
at the names you know that you can add
you can list reviews so I think that is
a much nicer way to sort of convey what
the app actually does and what you can
do with it and also looking at it you
kind of know that if you wanted to add
something you should probably look into
the adding package so it guides you
along a little bit this the hex model is
probably an overkill for simple apps
like this like the beer ad adding
package I just kind of deliberately
extended it I still think that there is
nothing wrong with flat files but again
just to give you an idea it's kind of
over complicated a little bit so maybe
thinking like okay that gets us into a
pretty good stage like it's a lot a lot
of a sort of slightly big mind shift
maybe and as that isn't even everything
I found about the design yet there is
also something called the actor model
and here's just like a quick Wikipedia
definition it treats actors as the
universal universal primitives of
concurrent computation and an actor
essentially can make decisions create
more actors send more messages or
determine how to respond to a message
received actors may modify their own
private States but can only affect each
other through messages avoiding the
needs of any locks that sounds an awful
lot like
concurrency patterns that you might have
heard about so essentially in the actual
model every object is an actor with a
mailbox and a behavior and all actors
communicate via messages they're all
independent they can all work as
synchronously that's kind of the gist of
it there's also no shared state between
the actors which again fits fits the
concurrent concurrency model an awful
lot and quite well so I thought well
okay no shared state that kind of
invites concurrency quite a lot and
indeed the the author of ddd vince van
Valen vernon and he he actually got
quite involved into popularizing the
actor model these days and it's only
been around for about I think since 2016
so it's a fairly recent trend and he
reckons that the actor model is well
suited for ddd and highly scalable
systems and potentially simpler to
implement than a typical event-driven
architecture
so again event-driven architecture
probably some of you got that idea
already
so I I don't have enough allot of time
left to show you a full demo but I did a
quick demo of how you could go about
that for the adding of sample data
so essentially what I've done is
introduced some go routines into the mix
and that kind of that actually is you
know it feels finally like proper go
programming so the idea is essentially
that our be rather in the review adder
there completely different actors and
they are they actually shouldn't affect
each other cuz they don't care about
each other so there's no there's no
reason why we wouldn't run them as two
go routines right like go add beers go
add reviews and then obviously the
messages that we're going to pass into
those actors are going to be the beer
data in the review data so the way I've
done it is thrown in the adding service
now defines the payload which in the
case of adding beers is just an array of
beers and in the case of adding reviews
it's an array of reviews so that's the
payload payload that this actor might
receive and then there are some events
that it might output so we can just say
I'm done I failed or beer already
so that kind of defines the events that
might be transported within and then if
you go back to the main I've also thrown
in some channels because we need a way
to know when those go routines finished
so you just pass in the channel 4 beers
done and reviews done kick off the go
routines and then we just wait for those
channels to return and then if if we get
the beers result we just print out a
simple summary of like finished with
status bla and if you get the reviews
done then you just print out finished
adding reviews so this is a very simple
simple thing about it I just kind of
wanted to give you an idea for how you
might go about defining those actors and
events and messages and going up
hopefully it looks a bit familiar like
Oh looks familiar to you if you've done
things like worker pools or
communicating with channels it's
essentially like the actor model is kind
of formalizing what you might have
already known from go programming and I
think that's why it fits go quite well
as a way to think about your apps a
quick word on testing I've not said it
much about it so far I think the best
thing is what the go authors would
probably recommend which is just keep
your test files next to your actual
files I don't think there is a much of a
reason to duplicate your package
structure in the test package I think
it's perfectly fine to keep the test
test files next to the main files I
think it's also fine to use a shared
mock sub package I think that's what
most people would recommend these days I
personally haven't found a reason to not
to so I'd say keep a shared mock space
sub package a quick word on naming I
touched on this before so I prefer my
package names to convey what the package
does then what it contains it's a it
sort of helps you reason about the apps
a bit more so choose the names that
suggest well what can be expected inside
avoid generic names like util or common
because that that just ends up being the
gigantic bag that you just throw stuff
in and then over time it just grows and
just it sort of has stuff that doesn't
fit anywhere else it's just asking for
trouble
a little bit there is a great talk by
Andrew gerund on the Damien go so I'd
encourage you to go in like six through
the slides it's published here and like
I mentioned before and that's the
idiomatic go avoid stutter so avoids
ending up in a situation where you might
have a beers dog beer or reviews that
review so same thing is strings reader
not a strings string reader just it's
even hard to say frameworks you might
you might have been thinking well should
I just use a framework is there a
framework that would just do all of this
for me yes and though there are some
frameworks out there like go buffalo and
go kit and a bunch of others the link
here at the top just list I think eight
or ten go frameworks from this year so
there are some frameworks out there and
I think it's worth checking them out to
get some ideas especially if you don't
know where to get started
but obviously then you have to stick to
that framework structure and personally
I prefer to learn and experiment with
this from like first principles so just
do it all myself rather than stick to a
framework and then I'm kind of forced to
keep to stick to a specific structure
like I said if you've been doing any
other languages like peach peace and
rubies you'll probably recognize the MVC
pattern in most frameworks the last link
here is something called the go build
template which is kind of like a
shortcut for creating the hex model it
will basically give you like a make file
a docker file as top level CMD package
and the package package and then leave
everything else for you to fill in so I
think that's actually quite a cool
shortcut that you could use
so to sum up putting it all together and
go I am a fan of the top level directory
structures so the CMD for your binaries
and inputs and then package for the rest
of your code keep your domain types
inside the root package dependencies or
the third-party things like storage
should ideally be in their own packages
because you can then swap them in and
out
mock's go in a shirt sub package all the
other files like docker files your
dependency management files anything
else I think it's fine to just stick it
in the root directory
the main package should be fairly small
so like the main docker function should
be fairly small you should just tie
everything together and then just
initialize the app avoid global scope
gets you into all sorts of trouble once
you have multiple packages and you have
to pass in a million dependencies
between them avoid in it as well like
the reason why I don't like in it is for
example if you put like I put the adding
of sample data in in it to start with
and then when I was writing my test and
my test would run the test would
obviously run the init function every
time so I would add sample data every
single time so it kind of gets you into
trouble very quickly because it will
always run I have to say that I have to
give a huge credit to those people
because none of these ideas is mine
originally this is what Peter Bergen and
Ben Johnson have been popularizing for a
while as a way to write go apps in 2018
so I highly recommend you check those
links they go into way more details than
like reasoning behind this Marco's Elson
as well he's done a talk here at golden
UK I think two years ago where he talked
about porting his sample DD app from
Java which is like a famous ddd example
into go so this is a way more
complicated app that he supported and
kind of tried to illustrate DDD on that
so again I highly recommend that you
check out his talk and his github repo
if you want to see a much more
complicated example of DDD so I'm sorry
I don't have a single right answer
there's usually no single right answer
to this
I like the code be like water by Bruce
Lee so be flexible your structure with
your structure don't be afraid to
experiment and adapt keep it as simple
as possible but not simpler
keep it consistent and share your ideas
as well if you come across if you just
discover a really good way of
structuring apps or if you have a really
good idea then like I did I said write
blog posts about it share your idea get
some feedback because I think we all
need we all need that and we can all
benefit from that so that is all I have
if you have any questions feel free to
tweet me I will publish the slides and
the code online and some references as
well like they're just a summary of the
ones that I mentioned so thank you for
listening
[Applause]